[Musique]
change seulement mon cœur
bébé,
m'aimer
[Musique]
oh tu t'en fiches,
accepte-moi gratuitement
[Musique]
Déchaîne mon cœur,
laisse-moi me laisser partir
[Applaudissements]
tu ne m'aimes plus
à chaque fois que je  t'appelle au téléphone,
un gars me dit que tu as hoché la tête chez toi en
frappant mon cœur
avant d'
utiliser mon cœur
[Musique]
mon cœur
parce que tu ne te soucies pas de moi
étranger
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
laisse-moi suivre mon chemin
[  Musique]
Libérez mon cœur
[Musique]
la misère
[Applaudissements]
quand vous ne vous souciez pas d'un sac de haricots pour
moi
Déchaîné dans mon cœur
[Musique]
des rires
mes portes baissent une chance s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
laissez-moi partir  à ma façon
bébé
[Musique]
tu t'en fous, s'il te plaît,
accepte-moi
gratuitement
[Musique]
merci